Haeju monkeys i cannot believe the
campaign against him one poster claims
on violent the other one says i just
represent the interests of the Roma
minority
Hungry's ruling Fidesz party has put up
400 posters to discredit the mayor
unfortunately Fidesz rhetoric is full of
anti-semitism and anti-roma sentiment
they're tapping into people's fears
trying to make me resign one year ago
marquis i became the mayor of haute
mezzo waha high which is surrounded by
foetus heartland he's a staunch
pro-european much to the chagrin of
prime minister or bonds Fidesz party and
he's vowed to tackle government
corruption and xenophobic propaganda
many Hungarians think that government
corruption is okay as long as Orban does
not let any migrants into the country
who allegedly raped their women and
steal their jobs unfortunately
governmental hate propaganda has worked
that's why marquis i propagates a
tolerant and open-minded atmosphere in
his town an EU flag again adorns the
cultural center and he encourages roma
events now hang my coat up here they
won't get stolen will it no we'll keep
an eye on it thanks we'll even put
something in your pockets
the mayor plays with anti-roma
prejudices it's all in good humor the
local Roma community appreciates their
jovial mayor unlike many others he
treats them with respect congratulations
your humane and you remain balanced in
these times marquise I used to
sympathize with orbán's policies but
over the past 10 years the independent
politician has completely changed his
stance it's important to us that Hungary
remain a democratic European state based
on the rule of law it's regretful that
our government has left his path
the Fidesz party holds a majority in the
hood mess over hey city council fierce
political exchanges are frequent it has
become evident in recent days that the
mayor wants to create a party that is
pro migrants and Pro immigration instead
of addressing the needs of the city and
its inhabitants we're rebuilding the
rule of law and democracy in Hungary
people are more courageous that's what
you take issue with though this will
require Hungary's opposition joining
forces as deputy mayor Andre akisha
explains our goal for the European
parliamentary elections is for the
right-wing populists Fidesz party to win
as few seats as possible and for the
opposition to take as many as it can
that's what we're campaigning for these
next days and weeks after a quick
meeting the mayor heads out for the
day's last campaign stop he says it is
crucial for him to meet voters in person
to convince them of his policies
especially now that he faces such a
formidable political foe this town hall
meeting is scheduled to debate policy
issues but pretty soon locals start
arguing over Hungary state of affairs
don't badmouth Fidesz I'll wring your
neck as far as I know Fidesz party
members were also invited to this event
why didn't they show up
I'll tell you why they're scared or
maybe because they're too busy too busy
making huge campaign posters
mayor marques eyes policymaking is not a
matter of course in Hungary today that's
why the 47 year old is now a household
name throughout the entire country